Oh, I can't help it in the circle of the helm No,
my chocolate is still missing, but
here it is Oh yeah, thank you for this, bye-bye
Ah, polish It's amazing that you
became an adult by giving chocolate to those children.
We're planning a plan from now on.At the
meeting, Jill said she could do whatever she wanted.Why did
that camera person come
out here?There's no such thing as being free to choose one's own freedom, right?  If I
act on my
own will, I am disqualified as an agent.I am always fighting based on my own will.If I
just stand by and watch, I am the one who
lives.I can't do anything unless I stand up for myself.You are just the
tools and equipment of the psychology department after all.  It's like that,
so I
went crazy.
Yonami no Banami no Banami no Bakomi no Baka.
Namino [Music] Idiot.